candida auras is a new
fungi or new fungus that have been
identified
and it is called emerging
fungal
infection it causes emerging fungal
infection
why
we are concerned about it because it is
multi-drug resistant in other words this
organism
could not be treated some some of these
strains in this
could not be treated by the anti-fungal
drugs we have currently
when patients are in hospital
what they do
catheters in them because of this these
bugs or these germs stick to the
catheter they make biofilm which is like
sticky material where it protects the
germs and this way you cannot get rid of
them what's so exciting about it is we
are now starting to look at
the role of microbes both bacteria and
fungi my research was the one that
brought the fungi or the fungus as you
say into the Forefront but other people
looked at bacteria
so when you put them together
this is where we start to understand
this could be a good guys they help us
or they could be bad if they are those
that cause disease
if we can develop this area and the good
news we are starting we may change the
way medicine is done we can prevent a
number of diseases
through taking care of our gut it's like
as they say everything starts in the gut
so that's what's the exciting thing I
think five to ten years we are gonna
change the way we
take care of ourselves based on This
research to me as long as we follow
the normal
reasonable way to keep germs away which
we should not go historic about it okay
and I think the CDC is really now
focusing on this area and they are
encouraging people to the scientists I
mean to look into ways how we can find
the news and factors how we can
decolonize the skin with how we can
treat systemic impact
the National Institute of Health they're
also now starting to pull money
this this is what makes America great by
the way when there is an issue we are
able to go after it and we find
Solutions
not all candida auras are multi-dragonal
system
s these are some of them which we can
kill using the currently used
antifungals but what we want to do is
develop new ways so that if there is a
strain or isolate from a patient that is
resistant to all the drugs available we
have new ways to do it and I assure you
we are finding ways that we can control
and that's why I'm optimistic about this
because I know we are gonna find a way